lecture pour tous reçoit aujourd'hui
hermeline de ville meuse bourse en
dernier roman le crépuscule des eaux
tantôt pourquoi chers hermeline le
crépuscule des hottentote
ou encore le député
mais dira-t-on tout ou tard il me
fallait être un titre
j'ai choisi celui-là à la loterie ou dc
d'être un adulte
c'est une image non revanche si la lute
a good la dépersonnalisation le drame
psychophysiologiques de ces adultes pour
qui j'ai créé d'ailleurs la ligue de
protection des majeurs contre les
mineurs c'est président attend mais vous
étiez surtout connu jusqu'ici pour vos
recherches sur la culture des finalistes
et des colos pendent
comment peut-on passer du jardinage au
roman à tendance sociale
c'est la même chose pour la montre kgc
d'iam ans et modestement nous porte et
me fruits mais qui vous a incité à
écrire ce roman
ma femme de ménage oui à la 7e
merveilleux zoologie que les gens ça
vous savez elle me disait toujours
madame cause comme un vrai bouquet alain
j'ai cru bon de grandir à florange
heures sur le cuir de cette jeunesse
intransigeante et des braves explique
certains jeunes n'accorde plus qu'une
somme dérisoire alors par an pour sortir
le soir
regarde étonnant si les parents sont
obligés de voler l'argent aux scolaires
de leurs enfants
comprenez vous oui certainement
certainement mais pourriez vous ce soir
pour nos amis téléspectateurs nous
parler de vos personnages
pesenti voici tout d'abord camille une
jeune fille très très bien et très pur
du meilleur goût agit de son groupe iii
sont riches et antiquaires elle
rencontre un adolescent de 17 ans dont
13 épatant lui même si depuis de famille
grand standing m'habiller et de démêlage
quoique cérébrale vous imaginez aisément
leur idylle
tous deux perdus dans la nature on
chanterait c'est le frémissant de l'euro
sa robe de regroupent et lila elle lui
glisse carrément à l'oreille ces
quelques vers que je ne peux pas
résister vais vous citer arrêts et
arrêts et ne me touche pas je trouve
super pitié d'eux sur quoi il lui répond
tout de go à raison alors troublé par la
conversation de ce jeune homme
elle perd la tête sa vertu ses bijoux de
famille ou t il la plume jusqu'à las
en fait il agit comme dirait mélina
comme un vrai dégueulasse
mais que devient camille dans tout ça où
la pauvre chérie couverte la preuve on
la dren devant les tribunaux pour
détournement de mineure savoureux maman
en apprenant la nouvelle
contractent une sorte de tizi galopant
cedro mère elle même qui était pourtant
très joueuse attrape les orions
je dois dire car à son âge à l'été vous
savez
très abîmé
on dit l'air de la campagne pas toujours
et puis j'aime avec vos escalopes sur la
figure comme divisa betar de la beauté
ne se vend pas le fait est apocalyptique
contexte de l'histoire mais livrent
chaque petit paragraphe ne serait plus
contre une cible pour le public de et
c'est bien là la fin de votre roman
pas du tout il ya cinq volumes à la page
2048 c'est l'envol mystique de camille
que l'on retrouve au couvent elle
apprend par la soeur tourriers en outre
l'oms et mathieu sont l'ex amant avait
quitté ses patrons l'emportant la caisse
séquestré c'est pas trop qui lui faisait
la morale mais le feu de ci de là avant
de s'enfuir en compagnie d'un jeune
teenagers enfin vous voyez tout ça est
très très moderne je dois dire que j'ai
vu paquet
et est ce là votre conclusion non il ya
un message vis donné par le garde chasse
qui a beaucoup vécu en angleterre je
crois ou en indochine s'étaient
brouillés
on voudrait aider les êtres on ne peut
rien a pour les êtres au cd biliton je
sais mais pas d'aigreur
et comme dirait ma bravo mais li na
toujours si pittoresque situé il y
aurait le carré blanc mais c'était une
très belle image